[Musique]
c'est une semaine lourde en symbole
qu'on vient de vivre collectivement avec
les manifestations contre le racisme et
la brutalité policière se sont
multipliées un peu partout vous venez de
voir donc le premier ministre justin
trudeau genou au sol dans une
manifestation hier à ottawa on en parle
ce matin avec les stratèges de l'image
et des communications martin saint
victor et louis aucoin est bien heureuse
de vous retrouver bonjour tous les deux
alors on a vu ces images de justin
trudeau genou au sol pendant environ
huit minutes avec les manifestations
hier même chose du côté du chef de
police de toronto
martin tout d'abord comment doit-on voir
ce geste qui a été posée maintenant je
crois que le geste du premier ministre
hugo est évidemment un geste de
solidarité
je pense aussi que le message qu'il
envoie un accès de non seulement les
noirs canadienne mais aussi à tous les
canadiens qui se sont jouées au maître
qui se sont joints aux manifestations à
travers le pays depuis quelques jours il
leur dit je vous vois je vous entends
c'est aussi une reconnaissance des
inégalités c'est aussi une
reconnaissance des revendications qui
ont été faits et un je pense que c'est
un message aussi de confort de
compassion et d'empathie
le chef de police de montréal avait
mentionné qu'il allait participer demain
à manifestation de montréal et
possiblement qu'il allait posé le même
geste en tout cas il allait étudier la
chose
louis aucoin ce matin il vient de nous
révéler en nombre que l'invitation qu'il
avait reçu de la part des manifestants a
été retirée ça crée une certaine bsb à
travers les organisateurs les
manifestants que de voir le chef de
police de montréal présent demain à la
manifestation
oui vous savez dans une situation comme
ça si vous êtes un policier ou encore
plus un corps de police dont vous êtes
sur la sellette vous devez réagir et
vous allez avoir nécessairement une
stratégie de communication pour une
chose
pouvez vous voulez faire changer les
choses ou bien vous voulez pas trop à
être atteint par la situation sur le
service de police de la ville de
montréal après désormais une stratégie
communication coup un peu sur se tenir
en retrait les situations contrairement
premier ministre hugo qui lui est allé
dans une prestation mais le genou par
terre et c est ce que de ce geste que le
chef de police de la ville de montréal
est capable de faire c'est d'aller à
cette manifestation non dodge est qu'il
peut faire par lui-même il les faits
portent donc sur une politique sur les
interpellations qu'elle va présenter au
mois de juillet oui c'est une politique
qu'on pourra mettre sur la table des
politiques du spvm donc il y en a eu
beaucoup bougé sur non seulement aux
années 2000 a eu lieu en 2004
l'une en 2006 des politiques ont des
profils âge une stratégie d'action en
2008 une nouveau plan stratégique 2012
2014 contre le profilage
présentement on est dans le plâtre 2018
2021 pour le profilage et malgré tout et
une étude l'automne dernier qui est
sorti pour vous les noirs ont quatre
fois plus de chances d'être arrêté royal
que les blancs et ça c'est la réalité
et qu'est ce qu'on connaît pour faire
place à une politique donc dans
l'opinion publique à un moment donné il
ya un phénomène de sédimentation où la
stratégie de communication mais elles
sont pas capables de traverser les vides
et qu'on se fait que que la police
tranquillement annonce des politiques
qui sont peut être les maîtres en
conséquence explication assez le
changement à force d'accumuler
finalement des promesses qui ne se
matérialise pas martin dans l'opinion
publique est ce que vous êtes du même
avis que louis là dessus oui c'est à
dire que les actions doivent suivre les
symboles je pense qu un exemple très
concret c'est ce qui s'est passé en
nouvelle zélande ya exactement un an
c'est-à-dire après la tuerie à la
mosquée la première ministre a subi un
alternat été visités les familles des
victimes tant religieux c'est un symbole
fort mais aussi ce qu'elle a fait une
semaine après la tuerie est là elle a
interdit les armes à feu la mise en
place des initiatives contre
l'islamophobie
donc voilà le genre d'actions qui sont
importantes et qui est ce qui dépasse
même les symboles je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on va faire ce que
les différents dirigeants va faire c'est
d'abord
hier des rapports parce qu'il y en a il
faut croire les rapports parce qu'ils
sont écrits par des gens qui savent
exactement ce qui se passe en l'air le
terrain et il faut annoncer concrètement
comment on va appliquer les
recommandations qui ont été faites
donc il ne suffit pas de mettre genou au
sol qu'on soit à politiciens ou chefs de
police il faut vraiment des actions
concrètes à faire du même coup louis est
ce sujet là concernant le chef de police
de montréal parce que c'est tout frais
en fait on vient d'apprendre qu'il ne
sera pas là demain
est ce qu'il lui fallait vraiment une
invitation pour se présenter
vous savez comment ça s'est passé hier
soir juste le repli hier dans la journée
il ya 10 juin vite les organisateurs
amélie à lui à la manifestation
c'est pas un très gros engagement ces
points non il remet dans les mains
d'autres personnes la responsabilité
pour lui de prendre une position non il
ya un gros gros problème aujourd'hui non
il ya une réunion qui doit se tenir au
service de police de la ville de
montréal ont décidé
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec cette
situation là qu'on arrête d'improviser
donc il faut prendre un leadership
à moins que on va se tenir loin du
problème mais si on veut quand même
temps de donner un message clair puis
être cohérent avec la liste de politique
je veux nommer tout à l'heure à
d'ouverture envers les communautés je
pense qu'il faut poser un geste
donc quel est ce geste je pense que ce
serait l'objet de la discussion
mais non une situation particulière où
l'actualité nous fournit le geste qu'il
faut poser pour être solidaire a donc
dit vous mettez un genou par terre c'est
le symbole que vous êtes déterminé à ce
que les choses changent
donc si nos gestes proposés aux très
compliqué donc quand on constate qu'ils
le fais pas ça contraste puisque
d'autres chefs de police on prépare le
chef de police de la ville de toronto
qui doit pas hésiter à poser ce geste là
et d'autres chefs de police des
centaines de chefs de police à travers
l'amérique
ainsi le geste avait posé comme un
carnet qu'il ya quelques années lors de
l'hymne national avant les matches de
football aux états unis martin en avait
quand même parler beaucoup à cette
émission l'étape des communications et
là au cours des dernières heures le
commissaire de la nfl roger goodell
dénonce les acteurs
esm et de pression fait son mea culpa
aussi dit que la ligue n'a pas agit de
la bonne façon en bannissant les joueurs
qu'ils poursuivent et continuer de poser
un genou au sol lors de l'hymne national
bon je pense que j'ai déjà souvent
évoqué ma position par rapport à la
ligue nationale de football
je vais pas est une association qui
cristallise justement la politisation de
trouver d'établir une digue en
dispensant des joueurs sont noirs de
toutes les équipes
capa importateurs qui est noir c'est un
unique ya toujours quand même été assez
assez sourde et aujourd'hui en fait je
pense qu'il faut le reconnaître le geste
du commissaire roger goodell maintenant
jusqu'à ses surprises que ce soit un
geste qu'il ait décidé de faire de son
propre de sa propre décision
je pense qu'on lui a tendu le bras mais
on s'est fait avoir dans les semaines à
venir
je pense aussi que c'est un message fort
parce que c'est un lorsque les
propriétaires de la vie lorsque les
forêts terme d' équipes n'ont pas depuis
quand une cape unique
il avait jusqu'en même dans leur camp le
président jobs est aujourd'hui le
président dont on se retrouve seul dans
son dans son indication de l'instance de
ce geste parce que même le quart arrière
du brise qui a fait 1
un revirement à 180° en deux jours pour
reconnaître qu'il avait tort reconnaît
qu'il avait mal été
certains de ces deux et koné a répondu
directement
hier à l'autre choc devant tout le monde
sur twitter pour lui dicter moi j'ai
changé d'avis je reconnais mes torts et
maintenant c'est à voir aujourd'hui dans
les jours à venir
d'abord comment le président plombe la
mariage il est aussi de voir ce que ce
que la ville va faire concrètement elle
a une initiative s'appelle rinspeed
ichange on va voir comment ça va se
traduire de papier que les bottines
suivent les babines comme on dit en
québécois
et quand on parle d'actions concrètes
louis est ce que vous estimez que la nfl
pour être vraiment qu'il réside dans son
mea culpa devrait même incité les
équipes a redonné
à copenhague parce que ça fait des
années qu'il ne peut pas jouer en raison
tout ça ça c'est le geste étalons qu'on
va attendre pour voir si la ligue est
vraiment sincère dans ses c'est vraiment
aussi et les professeurs il doit dire
que la ligue nationale fut pas de
problème de sédimentation dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure mais il existe
pour la ligue nationale de football
parce que à tolérer des gestes racistes
ou tolérer des gestes d'intolérance donc
il ya toujours au fil des années c'est
difficile de croire que aujourd'hui
soudainement et une prise de conscience
un chemin de damas et tout à coup la
livre totalement changé il va falloir
des gestes très forts et parce qu'on est
plusieurs un premier geste qui nous
vient le dcsp corinne cap qui a
publiquement remis rouge si donc au
moins un geste en vain de ramener au
juste une chose mais pour être le geste
envers karine copernic et d'autres
joueurs pour montrer la bonne volonté de
la ville
c'est incontournable sinon sinon c'est
une déclaration qu'on va avoir oublié
dans l'entrejeu